d'abord il ya une primaire à droite on a
beaucoup parlé ces derniers temps et la
droite parisienne a montré ce dont elle
était capable et en cela elle n'a pas
beaucoup changé 1 par rapport à ce qu'on
a connu dans les années précédentes
cette droite parisienne a aujourd'hui
une candidate sans surprise sans
surprise ne fait n'y ait pas d'être
surpris la primaire était organisé pour
cette candidate qui était la candidate
officielle elle fait un score moins 50
le oui que ce que les sondages lui
donner puisque c'était du 80 % qui lui
étaient attribués par les sondages il ya
quelques temps donc voilà la candidate
de la droite parisienne et là la
bataille la question se tait en ce qui
me concerne le choix que j'ai fait c'est
celui de rassembler cei je prends très
au sérieux les exercice démocratique je
prends très au sérieux tous les
adversaires et je prends très au sérieux
cette échéance je reparlerai mois de
reposer ma question est ce que vous avez
peur d'elle et les peurs du fait parce
que ça va être un manque à qui ça va se
transformer en bataille nationale c'est
ici alors vous savez moi je n'ai peur de
personne
moi je crois pas de personne je parle de
nathalie kosciusko morizet est donc je
n'ai peur de personne y compris le
nathalie kosciusko morizet il y à une
bataille dans laquelle je le souhaite
les parisiens se prononceront sur les
projets pour leur ville il y aura in
fine et un projet progressiste celui que
je vais porter un projet conservateur et
c'est au parisien dans la liberté la
plus totale c'est à eux de se nominer
pour cela moi vous savez la question des
personnes c'est un sujet bien sûr dans
un monde médiatico politique ou la
personnalisation est quelque chose
d'important j'ai ma part j'ai ma part et
je prendrai toute ma part je voulais
simplement ce qui va se jouer en mars
2014 c'est le destin harry je vais
givenchy mais je jouerai par des mois
vous demander de répondre justement là
où question que j'ai que que
j'envisageais à l'évidence il suffit
pour le voyage de françois hollande à
marseille pour soutenir aussi madame
carlotti ça va se transformer en
bataille nationale est ce que vous
pensez vous avez les épaules pour
justement affronté quelqu'un qui est
quand même peut-être plus que vous ce
qu'on considère peut-être à tort
d'ailleurs comme une leader national
témoin au leader national pas nationale
franchement je ne souffre pas d'un
manque de notoriété et je suis ancré à
paris mon combat c'est paris c'est pour
paris que la situation nationale pèse
sur l'ensemble des élections municipales
sans aucun doute mais faites moi
confiance ma personnalité et là aussi je
ne suis pas sortie de nulle part j'ai
une histoire une histoire politique une
histoire personnelle et une histoire
avec paris jean-luc prolongée